des imprimantes 3d pour produire des
visières des pièces pour les
respirateurs ou encore des tirs portes
pour quatre des visions distributeurs de
ces technologies implanté à guyancourt
la crise sanitaire n'a pas été de tout
repos
l'entreprise a notamment fourni 60
machines à l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris
quand on voit à l'échelle de l'ap-hp
c'est les 60 machines qui ont été
disposés c'est pas loin de 5000 pièces
qui sortent par semaine en fait les
techniciens de 4 des visions sont aussi
intervenus au technocentre renault de
guyancourt des ajustements techniques
sur des imprimantes 3d déjà présentes
sur le site industriel des machines
utilisées pour la production de 10 hier
et de pièces pour respirateur avec le
fabricant on a fait un travail de fond
pour essayer de trouver une solution à
leur ouvrir on va dire la machine
pendant la durée du coc vide à tunis en
ce matière qui serait capable d'être
avec ses 7 ces matériaux assez
spécifique au delà des leaders s'est
démené toute la partie dispositif
respirateur en fait où justement on
avait un besoin d'avoir un vieux con
tapis biocompatibilité et avoir
justement des matériaux qu'ils puissent
tester réalisable
la collaboration avec les groupes
industriels du territoire une activité
habituelle pour quatre des visions dans
le contexte de crise sanitaire les
échanges avec les clients étaient
centrées autour du principe de
solidarité